I was working out in the gym and as
often I do I was on Twitter in between
sets and reading about somebody else
doing something about the history of
philosophy I don't remember the exact
tweet that the head and then I thought
it would be kind of funny to put a
little query about terrible takes on the
history of philosophy so I did this
tweet that you can see right here let's
say I was going to write a history of
philosophy as all of you know in the
book market these days you need a novel
fresh perspective so what sort of stick
should I do only silly unfeasible and
terrible takes will be entertained and I
got a number of responses on Twitter it
started taking off now quite a few of
them were terrible in a way that I
wasn't looking for that means that they
didn't realize that I was asking about
something in a joking way and so they
gave me all these suggestions about you
know doing a history of philosophy that
wouldn't leave non-westerners out or you
know doing a good history of philosophy
you know and then lots and lots of
things about turning it into anime or
memes or things like that
that wasn't what I was actually looking
for silly unfeasible and terrible takes
that should have been like a clue that I
was looking for something joking around
and also a little imaginative I did get
a number of really great funny takes out
of that that made me chuckle so I you
know carried out these conversations I
also put it on Facebook and got quite a
few posts from people on Facebook both
along the lines of you know the straight
man who doesn't realize that there's a
joke being being made and some really
funny other suggestions so I thought I
would share the best of them best you
know as a very subjective term here the
ones that I thought had the most merit
in fulfilling the criteria the ones that
actually I got the biggest kick out of
and who knows maybe I will someday write
a history of philosophy a lock in the
lines
some of these but with no further ado
I'm going to share these with you
so this is probably the best one in what
we might call the absurdist category a
history of philosophy predicated upon
applying the maxim play stupid games win
stupid prizes to the history of
philosophy and like I said I have no
idea how I'd make it work but it's a
great idea I'd have to give that some
thought what would be the stupid games
and stupid prizes and how would we get
the different characters to jump through
those those hoops
what would we reward them with it's
worth thinking about isn't it
here's another funny suggestion
obviously you write a young adult novel
where the most popular philosophers and
the Western Canon are all high school
students at the same school with the
inevitable drama that would entail I can
already imagine scenes where nature
tries to convince everyone in the lunch
hall to only eat fruit for the rest of
their lives only to be interrupted by it
Diogenes holding a tomato and saying
behold the fruit obviously the reference
there is - Diogenes plucking a chicken
and saying behold a man because you know
human being had been defined as
featherless biped so this suggestion is
indeed you know quite a bit more
workable and complete I'm not sure that
I would be the one to actually pull that
off because I can't picture myself as a
young adult novel that's right
but it'd be interesting to think about
who fits into what clique so who's the
loner in the corner
you know philosophers maybe all of them
would be loners in a certain respect
although you know historically quite a
few of them were pretty convenient types
here's another good one one that made me
chuckle quite a bit why does everyone
hate me philosophy friends and life
decisions now I'm not sure how that
would be a history of philosophy but you
know there might be some way we could
make that work just about every
philosophical idea can be deformed in
some way as to be a terrible idea and if
you talk about it enough to everybody
around you or make decisions on the
basis of some of them maybe you drive
people away and then come to regret it
later and and we had some back-and-forth
it was quite good I said if you've
already got a trademarking off to find
some way to copy it just a close enough
and then the the interlocutor says it's
trademarked because I'm already on
chapter six so I think there's a little
bit of looser connection with the
history of philosophy but it's actually
not a bad idea
here's another great one that actually
could be pulled off in a way so ever
since Aristotle philosophy was just
emotions and feelings until early in the
21st century sam harris discovered math
and logic and i think there's a lot of
people out there who do buy into that or
it's fine rand or it's somebody else
right
Aristotle is usually the good guy
oftentimes Plato is somehow the bad guy
and then you know what do you do with
the Stoics and the Epicureans ah they
were just you know doing their own
private thing on their own so yeah I
mean that could actually be done and it
could be done in kind of a funny way
that would probably be quite appealing
because there's a lot of discussion if
you don't know it in the history of
philosophy of how the emotions work and
decision-making and stuff like that much
more than you get like in an intro to
philosophy class if you actually read
the texts of the thinkers you read into
their corpuses you'll find them
discussing these interesting things and
if you check out their biographies
there'll be some stuff about that so you
can do that and then you could present
Harris or pick you know whatever other
person you want as sort of the you know
person who is portrayed as the great
defender of logic rationality science
you know whatever buzzwords you want to
use and poke fun at them you know show
that that a lot of the thoughts that
they claim to have are actually not very
original that'd be a cool book
this one is a little bit of an inside
joke and really it's appealing to two
different communities this whole notion
of completing the system of German
idealism that was a big thing in the
19th century and everyone knows this is
the the new person on the scene who's
gonna finally bring everything to a
close and it lives on and meme culture
today among the young who you know joke
about this person or that person
completing the system of German idealism
now it couldn't be any diogenes that we
know not Diogenes the cynic nor Diogenes
Laertes because obviously it wasn't
around and neither of them would it be
the completer sort and then like I said
nobody ever completes it it's the
MacGuffin of philosophy you know there's
this notion of coming up with the final
system that's you know you could
actually do a lot of playing around at
that idea and I think that could make
for a funny history of philosophy this
is another great one I particularly like
this the entire work is just one passage
by Plato in quotes and 400 pages of
footnotes now why would you do that
because Alfred North Whitehead said that
you know the safest way to describe
philosophy is a series of footnotes to
Plato so you know we'd start with with
Whitehead zone reference to that and
then just keep on going imagine a book
like that you'd get it and we'd probably
have to put the footnotes a really
really small print so you can't even
read them unless you've got a mic not a
microscope a magnifying glass and it
being an incredibly frustrating book to
read maybe we do it with the paper
that's super thin as well and here's
another funny suggestion at least I find
it pretty funny a lot of people might
find it incredibly frustrating
encountered right do a history of
philosophy without naming a single
philosophy you say well there's this guy
and he said these things and then there
was another person and they said this
and that and I wrote well that's almost
what Hegel's doing in the phenomenology
if you ever read the phenomenology of
spirit it sure helps to know the history
of philosophy before you get into it
because he doesn't name names except
like Diderot you know for example so
yeah that that could actually be quite a
funny suggestion so here's a person
giving me a bunch of suggestions and I
thought you know one was actually quite
good
what would a stand-up comedy show take
on philosophy look like and so you'd
have to imagine like what would a
stand-up comedy history of philosophy
with all these different characters I
mean would they be doing the comedy
themselves presenting their ideas or
would I have to like come up with you
know little sticks and jokes about each
of them you know I'm sure it could be
done I don't know that I'm the person
who could actually pull it off but I
think it's it's kind of interesting and
funny project to suggest
so this is a funny exchange that I had
here present the entire history of
philosophy is a necessary teleological
progression with your very own
philosophy as its culmination I don't
doubt that you know many of my
colleagues would would love to do
something like that because it would be
so cool if they were at the center of
everything and I don't know maybe I had
some pretensions of doing that you know
decades ago but I don't actually
remember those and so I wrote well
that's been done lots of philosophers
have said I'm the one who's finally
brought it together and I said that's
been done and I don't really have my own
philosophy which is quite true I you
know I suppose I have some beginnings of
a philosophy but I don't know that it'll
ever be fleshed out and so the another
response this is the title of your new
history of philosophy that's been done
and I don't really have my own
philosophy and then the sequel would be
actually I do have a philosophy oh
that's great you don't have then the
next person you don't have your own
philosophy because it belongs to history
itself yeah I sort of just follow along
with it I'm more of a historian of
philosophy than anything else these days
although it's not history of philosophy
in the sense of dry arid discussions so
that's not a bad idea
here's my almost favorite my second
favorite suggestion a book that will
finally show that books with hot takes
showing that philosophy is dead are
themselves as a trend conclusively dead
I think he follows that philosophy is
dead is dead - Sadler 2020
unfortunately there's always going to be
smart idiots out there claiming that
philosophy is dead or metaphysics is
dead or ethics is finished or bla bla
bla bla bla because there's like a big
market I guess for claiming that you
know whatever take you have is the final
take and all they have to do is study a
little bit of the history of the
discipline maybe some other disciplines
as well to realize that all these X's
dead things are always premature we can
only say it when nobody really cares
anymore so yeah great great idea this
one is my absolute favorite and I think
it if it could be pulled off it would be
brilliant and you know I'm actually
tempted to try and take this on as a
project a history of philosophy that
fervently denies the existence of Hegel
and you know a lot of people today
aren't really that into Hegel but you
know if you know the 19th century you
know how it is vastly important he was
not just for German philosophy but in
the French area Italy the anglo-american
you know english-speaking world you know
analytic philosophy came out of a
reaction against British idealism which
is coming from from Hegel originally so
imagine that we are going to have a
history philosophy that says Hegel never
existed and so I wrote you know two
things that that is a funny one maybe
some other thinkers chosen at random as
well like we say Descartes never existed
or Augustine never existed it was all
just a made up thing or you know they
were confused at the time that would be
incredibly funny and then we get down to
the practicalities how to do it say that
the whole Hegel business was really a
hoax there was no such
I then the follow up is exactly Hegel
was just a fake name victim made up to
sell or write more books and then I
wrote that is awesome and maybe we have
shelling in on it too and then you know
we have Schopenhauer who who wanted to
position himself as Hegel's great you
know antagonist Hegel didn't really take
much notice of him after getting him a
job Schopenhauer gets brought in on the
hoax and has to moan about how bad this
Hegel guy is and then it gets even
better from what I hear Schopenhauer is
actually just shelling Waring and
extremely convincing wig fake facial
hair combo now that would be hilarious I
don't know that I have the chops to
actually pull it off but wouldn't that
be a brilliant piece of philosophical
satire I mean that would be worthy of
Lucian of Sam Soda if you don't know him
he was the great satirical writer who
who managed to go after pretty much
every school of ancient philosophy back
in his own time just a very funny guy
somebody who is well worth reading so
this this is a just a really great idea
I was so happy to get these funny
suggestions and this one really caps it
what was originally just sort of joking
throwaway tweet actually wound up coming
up with some pretty cool ideas I don't
know that I'll ever have the time to do
any of these but I think some of them
could actually be quite worthwhile not
that they'd actually contribute much to
our understanding of the history of
philosophy but there's plenty of other
people doing that work already I think
there's you know room for joking around
and and comedy and humor and so you know
I know they sort of brightened up my day
reading through them I got a lot of good
laughs out of out of some of them
especially that last one of the Hegel
idea and hopefully you have gotten a
kick out of that as well
you